[Music]
in the entire history of the Soviet
Union there was not a single planned and
peaceful leadership transition
of the eight Communist Party secretaries
in the nearly seven decades between 1922
and 91. six ruled until they died one
was overthrown and Gorbachev saw the
dissolution of the entire state
in fact there had never been a peaceful
Handover of power in any major communist
country
until the early 2000s when Chinese
leader Zhang Zim Min voluntarily
resigned
for the first time in the nation's
history there was no coup no Intrigue no
political infighting
Zhang semen even endorsed his successor
despite having not chosen him
no one was calling China a liberal
democracy but it seemed as though the
days of one man rule were finally over
term limits were instituted
anyone over the age of 68 was expected
to retire
and each successive leader from Mao
Zedong to dung Xiaoping to Jung Sim Min
to hujin Tao was less powerful than the
last
the phrase being floated around at the
time was intra-party democracy
in other words there may only be one
party but within it there was plenty of
room for healthy competition
[Music]
from here on out policies would be
debated leaders would rotate out and the
best ideas would win
[Music]
then one man Xi Jinping reversed all
this progress
she is about to begin his third term in
office and with neither a designated
successor nor hardly any competition
there's no end to his role in sight
so how did China revert from intra-party
democracy to one-man rule in a single
generation
how does any of this the Chinese
Communist Party actually work
sponsored by curiositystream and nebula
nebula is the only place you can watch
all poly matter videos including my
ongoing series China actually for just
fifteen dollars a year with the
Curiosity stream and nebula bundle you
can watch all five of those videos over
90 minutes of exclusive content and much
more to come
every five years typically in October or
November about 2 300 people from across
China travel to the Great Hall of the
people in Beijing for What's called the
National Party Congress
this year for example is the 20th party
Congress which began on October 16 2022.
because it's designed to appear
representative of society most of these
2300 people called delegates are
relatively low ranking party members
they include everyone from Farmers to
celebrities Factory workers and mayors
likewise to create the veneer of Harmony
ethnic minorities are awkwardly paraded
around in their traditional dress
the whole thing is a giant spectacle
there are giant red curtains with golden
tassels and more clapping than an
American State of the Union
the party takes no risks in the run-up
to the country's most important
political events
vpns which although illegal are
ordinarily tolerated for use by
foreigners and the technologically savvy
suddenly stop working
dissenters are preemptively put under
house arrest police patrols are doubled
and private businesses both Chinese and
foreign are warned not to Reign on the
party's parade by making any major
announcements
yet for all this Showmanship the actual
event is exceptionally boring
it may be theater but not the kind
anyone would voluntarily watch
on the first day for instance the party
secretary delivers a long speech called
the political report reflecting on the
past five years and setting the
priorities for the next
it's here that you're reminded how
incredibly leninous the Communist party
is still very much remains
rather than specific policies or plans
you might hear about the three
represents four comprehensives or
strengthening of confidences
it's only by deciphering these vague
slogans that China Watchers infer where
the country is headed it's an entire
language of its own
after this the 2300 delegates quote
study the speech and inevitably accept
it without challenge
that's because the real decisions have
been made much earlier
although the party doesn't acknowledge
this fact officials meet in secret at a
summer Resort east of Beijing in August
the second item on the agenda is to
amend the party's Constitution
again no laws are being written here
only ideological statements
in 2017 for example XI jinping's name
was added implying that he's not just
another politician but a great figure in
party history
finally at the end of this week comes by
far the most important task when
delegates elect members of the Central
Committee
elect in quotes because remember almost
everything has already been decided
in 2017 delegates had 222 candidates to
choose from for 204 seats giving them
the option to reject just nine percent
those 204 people then became members of
the Central Committee the next level up
in the party hierarchy
there are almost as many alternates who
attend meetings but aren't allowed to
vote they can replace full members when
they die or lose their positions
the Central Committee meets at least
once a year in what's called a plenum
and the first plenum occurs the day
after the party Congress ends this year
on October 23rd
their most important task is to elect
members of the 25-member political
Bureau or politburo another level up in
the party hierarchy
[Music]
the politburo in turn elects a standing
committee of usually seven or nine
people one of which is the General
Secretary of the party in this case Xi
Jinping
notice the phrase General Secretary not
president
China is a party state which means it
has a government and a single ruling
party
the two mirror each other in many ways
but they aren't the same
the state confusingly has its own
version of the National Party Congress
called the national people's Congress
and to make things even more confusing
multiple parties participate in the
people's congress not just the Communist
Party
but they're all members of a single
united front which means they co-exist
not compete with the CCP
anyway just as the party Congress helps
elect a general secretary every five
years in the fall on the party side the
people's Congress elects the country's
president and Premier every five years
in the spring on the state side
though don't think of the party and
state as entirely separate either
there's lots of overlap
virtually everyone working for the
Chinese state is a party member but not
all party members work for the state
after all there are nearly 100 million
party members
as general secretary Xi Jinping is head
of the party and as president he's Head
of the State these are two different
roles that could be filled by two
different people
but they're not which gives him the
choice of which to use at any given
moment
when she visits a foreign country unless
that country is say communist Cuba or
North Korea he does so as the president
of China
that's technically true he is in fact
the president but there's a growing
movement in favor of always calling him
General Secretary
in China the party is above the state
the people's Liberation Army reports
directly to the party not the government
a city's party secretary is given the
license plate number one and it's mayor
too trivial as this may sound it is
telling
the CCP even has its own separate
justice system
in other words XI jinping's most
important titles are General Secretary
and head of the military not president
which is mostly a ceremonial role
the common use of presidents many argue
is a deliberate strategy on China's part
to obscure the party's importance
it wants to appear to investors like any
other country not one where your private
property might be confiscated for
political reasons
but in truth even the title General
Secretary is a bit misleading
in most countries a person's position in
government is what makes them powerful
Joe Biden is powerful because and for
the most part only because he's
president of the United States
sure former presidents are celebrities
but Fame is not to be confused with
power
this all Probably sounds exceptionally
obvious but it's not true in China
take an example have you ever heard or
seen a photo of dung Xiaoping
what about John to Young
chances are the answer is yes to the
first question and no to the second
dung is the iconic Pioneer of China's
reform era while Zhao is forgotten by
all but students of History yet Deng
Xiaoping was never General Secretary
Zhao was
instead dung is referred to as a
Paramount leader an informal nickname
not an official position
when dung famously traveled to Shenzhen
calling for more economic reform he was
87 years old and fully retired yet
powerful enough to steer the country's
Direction
you don't need any specific title to
wield considerable political power in
China even the most political power and
conversely neither does holding any
specific title guarantee power
the watershed moment in Chinese history
when Zhang semin peacefully handed over
power to hujin Tao in 2002 is not quite
What It Seems
in reality Jung quietly stayed on as
head of the military until he was
heavily pressured to step down in 2004.
like China's Embrace of capitalism the
party's Conformity to consistent rules
and Norms has always been a mix of our
wishful thinking and their skillful
performance
even age limits which were seen as a
positive sign that no one would be
allowed to rule forever turned out to
merely be a way for zhangs and Min to
purge his Rivals and the limit has been
broken when convenient sins when China
made headlines in 2018 for removing term
limits that was for the office of
President there have never been term
limits on party's secretaries meaning Xi
Jinping could have already stayed in
power indefinitely
what all this means is that in China
power isn't automatically conferred by
office
it has to be one
its leaders generally arrive relatively
weak and slowly trying to consolidate
authority over time
it took Jung Sim Min nearly six years to
wrestle control after being named
General Secretary who Jin Tao arguably
never did
what makes Xi Jinping unique is not so
much his hunger for power but the speed
with which he acquired it
as we've seen there were very few actual
rules preventing him from accumulating
power it was simply a question of
political skill and luck both of which
he had and droves
she is what you might call a prince Lane
his father was a revolutionary fighter
and high-ranking Party official
meaning as a child he had both privilege
and likely a sense of entitlement his
red blood made him destined for the
throne
now make no mistake princelings have
shifted in and out of favor over time
as a teenager during the cultural
revolution she was sent to learn from
the proletariat by doing manual labor in
the countryside
he lived in a cave and his father was
arrested
later after Mao's death in 1976
princelings were revived as the party
Revisited its past
she like many of his Elite peers landed
a promising job in governments
but unlike his peers Xi Jinping kept his
head down
thanks to their connections princelings
had no trouble securing jobs but very
rarely were they promoted to the very
top where their superiors thought they
might cause trouble or even threaten to
replace them
instead says expert in Chinese politics
Victor XI they tended to promote quote
always nice people weak cadres who
obediently followed orders
she on the other hand avoided the
Spotlight by taking relatively low
profile jobs outside of the city where
he quietly climbed the ranks
by the time he reached the Apex of power
in 2012 Not only was he better connected
than most of his peers but ironically he
also benefited from this discrimination
against princelings he didn't have much
competition
these are all the polyp Bureau members
before he became General Secretary
ranked according to the size of their
political Networks
basically his competitors
first we can remove anyone due for
retirement they obviously aren't much of
a threat
next let's remove all the
non-princelings who lack the connections
and privileges
institutional sexism effectively
disqualifies all women
we can also remove this person because
of a reputational stain his brother
defected to the United States
that leaves she with only three major
competitors
boshilai was subsequently arrested and
the other two were quietly demoted to
the unimportant vice president position
he then reorganized the military
launched an enormous anti-corruption
campaign that helped Purge Rivals and
enshrined his name in the party
Constitution
today Xi Jinping is effectively
unchallenged making him more powerful
than any Chinese leader since Mao
yet she is not Mao
the challenge to understanding China is
learning from its past without losing
sight of the present which is what I
tried to do in my nebula original series
China actually each video we tried to
solve a puzzle about China like why some
protests are tolerated and others not or
why it's still trying to maintain zero
cases of covid in late 2022
you can watch all these full-length
exclusive videos and more to come on
nebula the streaming service myself and
other educational creators founded where
we don't have to worry about the YouTube
algorithm
nebula is partnered with curiosity
stream which is home to Great
documentaries on science nature and
history like this true story of one of
the Soviet Union's most notorious spies
when you sign up to curiositystream for
just 15 a year with a link in the
description or on screen now you also
get free access to nebula where you can
watch my videos and countless other
exclusive Originals ad-free videos and
bonus content and for the record that's
not just a trial you get access to both
services for the same low price as long
as you stay subscribed